America everyone knows it's the greatest
nation on earth and our leaders are the
greatest leaders on earth but did you
know there are other countries that are
not America and each of them has a
leader of its very own let's take a
moment to meet one in our ongoing series
other countries presidents of the United
States
this week's leader Francois zhalong
Prince wah Holland Francois Hollande
from Frankie Holland that's right
Francois Hollande the president of
friends the country where your cousin
spent a three-month semester abroad and
the rest of his life over emphasizing
the word Wausau interestingly alone is
rare among world leaders in that he's
publicly questioned the existence of God
which perhaps explains why on his
inauguration day this happened along is
on his way to meet with German
Chancellor Angela Merkel in Berlin when
his plane was hit by lightning Hollande
is also a committed socialist not only
believing that France should have a
public investment bank and that the
country's retirement age should begin at
60 but also that his body should be
shared with as many French women as
possible
yes Francois is probably most famous for
his love life which rivals that of
France's notorious president look you we
can do away with these dolls to the
limit of ease Elan had four children
with ségolène royal a fellow socialist
who also ran for president only to lose
to Nicolas Sarkozy along chose to
comfort his partner by leaving her for
his younger mistress Valerie
Kyle viola an act so heartless the
French people decided to punish him by
electing him to the highest office in
the land
but wait there's more Hollande then
cheated on his mistress with another
mistress sneaking out of the
presidential palace to meet her for
rendezvous on a scooter a sequence of
events so stereotypically French it's
almost offensive so tonight we introduce
you to Francois Roland
a man who dumped a presidential
candidate and became president himself a
man who evicted the first lady from the
presidential palace an action would
somehow increased his approval ratings
and the only man in the world who's
managed to pick up a gorgeous movie star
mistress while riding around on a
scooter who says there's no God
you